(audience cheering)
(fun upbeat music)
(Neil laughing)
- I'm gonna get to your
dance moves in a minute, sir.
- No, ah, no.
- We have been around
each other too many times
for me not to know that you are a dancer.
- Oh, well, yeah, yes.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes!
- But I don't tell people that.
- Oh, I'm sorry, let's go ahead
and bring up this photo.
Yep, look at that chest hair!
- [Neil deGrasse Tyson] Oh!
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly Clarkson] Look it, out to play!
- [Neil deGrasse Tyson] Oh!
(audience cheers)
- I had no idea.
- Wait, Kelly, that was 50 pounds ago.
- Whatever.
(Neil laughing)
- If you can measure time
by weight accumulated.
- Wait, were you talking
like that to the dancers?
(Neil and Kelly laugh)
- No, no, I was a performing member
of three different dance
companies in my day.
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's amazing.
- In other day.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes.
- In a different chapter of my life.
(audience laughing)
Yes.
- Groovy and you can groove, I like it.
- Well no, I like that,
there's nothing like dance shape.
Because you're strong, you're limber,
you're flexible.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- And graceful.
- Totally, just like me.
(Neil and audience laughing)
Just like
just like me, that's what I say.
You just celebrated a birthday.
- Yes.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes!
- I'm an official old, crusty man.
- Whatever.
- Yeah, two weeks ago I turned 65.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my
God, that's incredible.
- Yeah!
(audience cheering)
- I say it's a blessing, not everybody
I love age, because it's a blessing,
not everybody gets that.
- So here's the thing, here's the thing.
Don't get old unless you
have wisdom to show for it.
(audience clapping)
- Oh, man.
(audience laughing)
it's like the fortune cookie I get
but don't understand.
(Neil and audience laughing)
It sounds so cool when you say it.
- That's how I feel,
that's how I'm feeling it.
- Well we knew that it was your birthday,
so we have wine for you.
- Oh my gosh, I little bit of pinot noir.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I
know you like red wine.
(audience cheering)
- [Neil deGrasse Tyson] Thank you.
- [Kelly Clarkson] You like
red wine, so for your birthday.
- [Neil deGrasse Tyson] Thank you.
- This is from our friends
at Duckhorn Vineyards,
and this is a 2021
Kosta Browne pinot noir.
- Definitely pinot noir, thank you.
- I love pinot.
- I'm all into pinot,
thank you, thank you.
- Wait but your favorite
is a burgundy, right?
- Well burgundys, the red burgundys
are mostly pinot noir, so I'm all in.
- Oh I don't know that much about, okay.
(audience laughing)
- What now you tell me?
Now it comes out.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Girl,
okay, I'm just telling you.
- You gonna go there
and not go all the way.
- Look I go to the wine
tasting and they're,
"Oh, do you taste the oak?"
"Totally."
Like.
(Neil and audience laughing)
It just tastes like something that's gonna
get me to a good time,
you know what I'm saying?
(audience cheering)
- That can happen, too.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's gonna happen too.
- So other than dancing,
were you always into science?
Like when a kid, birthdays,
did you ask for space gifts?
I figure you did.
- Well I can tell you,
so my earliest, I was nine
when my parents took me
to the Hayden Planetarium
here in New York City.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh, that's cool.
- [Neil deGrasse Tyson] I'd
never seen the night sky.
Well, they showed me the night sky
in the Planetarium, there
were thousands of stars.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- This is beautiful, but it's a hoax,
because I've seen the
night sky from the Bronx.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
There's like eight stars,
this is not the right night sky.
I would later of course learn
that that was the real night sky.
To this day, when I go to mountaintops,
the greatest observing
sights in the world,
and I look up and I say,
"It's so beautiful."
"It reminds me of the Hayden Planetarium."
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- No, I'm telling you,
at some point, no joke,
you have to come to my ranch in Montana.
It is the most beautiful
sky you will ever see.
- You know the last time you had a ranch
and an eclipse went on your property,
I didn't get a call from you.
- I know, but that's because,
but I didn't say, "Oh
I'm gonna invite you."
Now I'm saying I'm inviting you.
- Okay, we got this on record.
- But I didn't know that was gonna happen,
in my defense.
But it was cool.
- [Neil deGrasse Tyson] Oh yeah.
- Not to rub it in.
(Neil and audience laughing)
- But not it's such a
beautiful thing to behold.
- Yeah, Montana, big sky.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my God.
- It's not an accident.
- And it feels like you
can touch the stars.
- [Neil deGrasse Tyson] Yeah!
Something I never felt in the Bronx.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- That's what that was.
By the way, when I was
dancing, by the way,
I was still studying astrophysics.
And I had fellow dancers
who were making extra money,
'cause I needed money
'cause we weren't paid much.
- Yeah.
- And one of them said,
"Why don't you come down with us?"
'Cause some of them
danced at a strip club.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my God.
- Like a guys strip club for the women.
- Do you have a picture?
- No, no!
(everyone laughing)
No, no, no, no.
But I just wanted to clarify.
- Make it my birthday.
(audience laughing)
- No, no, let me clarify
that
so I went, I was cut and
I could do a full split,
so I was-
- Oh.
- But I went to just investigate, right?
I wanted data first.
- Yeah.
- So I go there-
- Data?
- Yes!
So I'm watching them come out
and they had asbestos lined jock straps
that had been ignited with lighter fluid,
and they came out dancing
to Jerry Lee Lewis'
song "Great Balls Of Fire".
(audience laughing and cheering)
Now, now, now, now.
- Oh my God, this place was awesome.
- Let me just say,
I'm embarrassed that only in that moment
when I saw their genitals on fire
did I say, "Maybe I
should be a math tutor".
(audience laughing)
- "Maybe there's another way".
- I didn't before that,
but that's stupid, I coach.
- You're using your dance skills.
- I could totally tutor math,
and it didn't occur to me to do so.
- Imma be honest with
you, like I've never been
to a strip club, not
against 'em, do your thing,
but I've never been to one.
But like if I were to go to one,
I don't think a lot of
balls are being on fire
at a lot of them, I think that was
a very specific strip club.
- It was, I'm just saying, at that point
I had other thoughts
about how to earn money.
- You're like, "I'm gonna
keep this junk safe".
You have a new documentary.
- I love that, "Earth's own", I like that.
- Well, we're proud of you.
- I am from Earth.
- You're one of the good of human kind,
of mankind, yeah.
(Neil laughing)
But you have a new documentary,
let's talk about it.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I served as script editor
and executive producer on a documentary
that explored anti-science thinking.
- Ah.
- In our culture, and how
that influenced people
to not be vaccinated.
- Wait, are you talking about
people like flat-earthers?
- Well, they would become
under the broader category
of anti-science thinkers.
- Oh, you're doing it in a
PC way, I see, okay, okay.
(audience laughing)
- Right, right, right, no there's a whole
camps of people who think
something is true that is not.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes.
- And science, the methods
and tools of science
are exquisitely tuned to establish
and enable and empower you to distinguish
what is true when you
otherwise think it's not.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Mhm.
- Or what is not true when
you otherwise think it is.
And so this is what science does,
find objective truths in the world.
That's what led to this
quote, I say it again,
the good thing about
science is that it's true
whether or not you believe in it.
- Yeah.
- [Neil deGrasse Tyson] Okay?
(audience cheering)
- Now the moving frontier
can be ratty, okay?
But once a result is
established and verified
by other labs and things, then hey,
we've discovered a new objective truth
about the world, and
you can't debate that.
- Yeah, I agree with that.
- And by the way, so I was brought on
as script consultant, and then elevated
to executive producer by the
director, writer, and producer,
Scott Hamilton Kennedy,
who's a documentarian.
In fact, he's in the audience right now.
- Oh.
- Where is he?
Scott, there we go.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I
was like, "Right here".
Yeah, yeah.
(audience cheering)
- He's done other films.
- Yeah.
- Just trying to explore
just how we get truth out there
where people think it's not.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Absolutely.
- And this is an important place to be,
especially today we have
these warring factions
when everyone thinks their right.
- Especially if you're a trusted person.
- Yes.
- That people, yeah.
- Entirely.
- Yeah, 'cause it's hard.
Sometimes media, how they navigate it,
it can be hard.
- Right.
- To know where to put your trust.
- So this past week it
premiered in New York,
and it's gonna premiere in Los Angeles.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- At the end of November.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Cool.
- So if I can give the website,
ShotInTheArmMovie.Com.
- "Shot In The Arm",
that's the book, right?
There's the book.
- Oh no the book is something else,
I'm doing a lot of different things.
- Look at you, okay, go, what's the book?
What's the book?
(audience laughing)
Talk about the book.
- So six weeks ago, I published a book,
co-authored, called "To
Infinity And Beyond".
- Oh, "To Infinity And
Beyond" yes, I love it,
Buzz Lightyear, okay.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- And it's co-published
with National Geographic.
- Yeah.
- So it's a beautiful book,
'cause they don't make ugly books.
- [Kelly Clarkson] No, they're beautiful.
- [Neil deGrasse Tyson]
That's not how they roll.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Okay, and so it's an exploration
of what it was to stand
flat-footed on Earth,
look up and just wonder
how would you ever ascend?
Icarus tried it with his wax wings,
they melted, or died, okay.
But what's your next thought?
Is it, "I will never try that again" or,
"Maybe I should make wings"
"out of a different material next time."
- Yeah.
- And so this book is an homage.
- The Wright Brothers.
- To all the people who kept ascending
to every next point that
was previously imagined
at infinity, and then you go beyond it.
- Yeah.
- So we put people on the Moon,
but our robotic emissaries
have been to Mars,
Jupiter, Saturn, and beyond.
To contemplate the origin
of the cosmos itself.
- It's very smart, it's very clever.
- Yeah, it keeps you
going, it keeps you in it.
- It keeps us into it.
- The little biscuits along the way, yeah.
- Little biscuits, okay.
All right, let's get to the best and worst
part of space.
So every time Neil is here,
he tells me something
terrifying about the universe
that I end up Googling for weeks.
- [Neil deGrasse Tyson]
Because you ask me.
- I know.
I know, 'cause I wanna
know, I'm a prepper, okay?
I like to be prepared, so
it's something we call...
(exciting rock music)
♪ Neil scares Kelly half to death with ♪
♪ Space facts ♪
(audience cheering)
(Neil laughing)
What?
Oh my God.
Oh my God, I didn't know what was coming.
(audience laughing)
(Kelly laughing)
All right, so, you're welcome.
- Freaked me out right there.
(audience laughing)
- You know what, in fairness,
you're about to scare the
hell out of all of us,
so go ahead, what's one thing?
- Okay, you wanna know ways we might die
delivered by the Universe?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes.
- Okay, so we just brought back a sample
from an asteroid called Bennu.
This is an asteroid whose
orbit crosses Earth's orbit.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Okay.
- There it goes.
And any asteroid that
crosses Earth's orbit
will one die collide with Earth,
it's just a matter of when.
Asteroid Bennu, it will
cross Earth's orbit
and we think it could hit us,
with a one in about 3,000
probability, in 2182.
- That's not far.
- Okay, so, no it's not far,
and the asteroid's about the size
of the Empire State Building.
So, no, it won't render us extinct.
But wherever it hit would be really bad.
(audience laughing)
Okay, so, so, but 160 years,
that's plenty of time
to find Bruce Willis.
- Exactly!
(audience laughing)
Get him up there.
- No it's plenty of time
to figure out how we might-
- No there's no way to
protect us from that?
- No!
(audience laughing)
No.
(Neil laughing)
Listen, no.
We have no, there are no-
- Why don't you shoot at it?
- No!
There's no plans right
now to deflect anything,
we are sitting ducks, and you know
that dinosaurs, had
they had a space program
they'd still be here.
(audience laughing and cheering)
- I love you so much.